good afternoon it is truly an honor to
introduce today's guest preparing
students to lead has been a cornerstone
of this university since our founding
over three centuries ago as John Quincy
Adams once said if your actions inspire
others to dream more learn more do more
and become more you are a leader and
surely this definition suits our
distinguished visitor Her Majesty Queen
Rania Al Abdullah has led by example
from the moment that she entered public
life with varied interests and boundless
energy Her Majesty is actively involved
in worthy causes that affect the lives
of citizens in Jordan and people all
over the world
Her Majesty's interest in family welfare
particularly education occupies much of
her time Her Majesty is chair of the
Jordan Education Society which is
dedicated to improving and modernizing
Jordans education system
she's also patron of the Madras Adi
School Montessori program roughly
translated my school which helps
refurbish disadvantaged public schools
throughout Jordan Her Majesty's impact
on the world stage has been equally
impressive she is an acknowledged
humanitarian and advocate for the less
fortunate
in July Her Majesty became the honorary
chair of the United Nations girls
education initiative she's been a
long-standing patron of UNICEF for over
a decade
Queen Rania has been a passionate voice
for cross-cultural dialogue and the need
for peace she is focused on providing
spaces for the world's youth to come
together in a spirit of peace and
respect to discuss differences and the
challenges of our times Her Majesty's
desire to reach young people has made
her one of the most accessible of world
leaders today in March 2008 Queen Rania
launched her own channel on YouTube
dedicated to creating better
understanding of Islam and the Muslim
world in November 2008 over
three million by November 2008 over
three million people had visited this
channel and this year Her Majesty began
the revolutionary work of using Twitter
over 700,000 people from every corner of
the globe have responded to her tweets
Her Majesty has also been a proud patron
of the Arts of particular notes she
helped in 2000 to sponsor and inaugurate
an exhibition of magnificent works of
female artists entitled breaking the
veils women artists from the Islamic
world this exhibition has travelled
throughout the Muslim world and is
toured in Europe and the United States
and I am very proud to say is currently
on exhibit right here at Yale at the
Institute for sacred music the breaking
the veils exhibit is but one of the many
activities and programs that take place
here on the Yale campus with a focus on
the contemporary Middle East in recent
years we've vigorously increased our
campus activities and course offerings
in this field we now have a modern
Middle Eastern Studies major we have
eight new faculty members teaching
courses related to the contemporary
Middle East each year we bring
distinguished scholars from the region
to enhance further the discourse on our
campus and as demonstrated by their
wonderful Ramadan banquet that took
place last week in the Yale Commons Yale
is a place where Muslim students and
scholars are welcomed and embraced with
respect
Yale students faculty and alumni have
also been active in Jordan as well as
throughout the region of particular note
students and faculty from this school of
architecture here are involved in the
creation of a proposed peace park which
will be built on the banks of the Jordan
River beginning in 2010 Yale college
students will be able to study Arabic at
a Yale study at a Yale summer study
program in Jordan and we hope that the
number of students and scholars from
Jordan will grow in the future we're
very proud of the small but excellent
number who are here right now to
symbolize our commitment to building
strong relationships in the Middle East
I'm very pleased to announce today the
creation of a queen rania fellowship for
the study of the contemporary Middle
East it's my sincere hope that students
who become Queen Rania fellows in the
near future will not only learn about
the region while they're here but will
also contribute to scholarship on this
significant part of the world in every
generation there are leaders who stand a
little taller than those around them
whose light shines a little brighter
than their contemporaries today we're
honored to host such a figure and with
that let me introduce our guest Her
Majesty Queen Rania Al Abdullah queen of
the Hashemite Kingdom of Jordan
Prison 11 Dean Lorimer faculty students
thank you so much for making me feel so
welcome here at Yale I wanted to come
here for many years and I'm so grateful
to everyone for the hospitality and
kindness you've shown to me and my staff
I've really been looking forward to
seeing the Yale landmarks that I've
heard about for so long now the my Nikki
by Nikki library harvest our old campus
Peterson Loomis mustache oh I'm sorry I
didn't make it quite in time for that
last one but everything else is even
more impressive than I'd imagined this
is a spectacular place indeed I have to
admit as I was preparing for this visit
I wondered what an earth I could tell
you that you didn't already know
yay Leigh's have won 17 Nobel Prizes six
presidential elections and even two
Heisman trophies you can choose from
more than 2,000 courses browse more than
12 million books in the libraries make
friends for more than 110 countries and
as far as I can tell from the posters
all around campus try it for 3,000 a
cappella singing groups
so rather than try to compete with all
of that I thought I'd speak from my own
experience I thought I'd offer an hour
perspective on my part of the world and
our hopes for peace and progress
especially with regard to the
israeli-palestinian conflict and I'm
guessing since you made the time to be
here today when you could have been
doing something really important like
researching a paper or visiting a
professor or calling your mom to tell
her just how much you love her that this
is an audience that already cares about
international relations but I do realize
that foreign policy isn't typically a
top concern for the American public and
especially not in a time of economic
hardship at home a poll earlier this
year found that 75% of Americans agreed
terrorism should be one of President
Obama's top priorities but almost no
other foreign policy issues made it to
the top 20 list so I don't expect that
the arab-israeli conflict is foremost on
most people's minds yet in many ways
that conflict is at the core of US Arab
relations or at least at the core of our
public opinion of America when Arabs
were asked in a poll the spring were two
steps by the US would improve their
views of the United States the most more
than 40 percent said a peace agreement
between Israel and Palestine the same
poll found that 99 percent of people put
the conflict in their top five
priorities and one in three say the
Palestinian issue is their number-one
concern
that's because for us the occupation is
a hurt we feel each day in Jordan nearly
a third of our population are
Palestinian refugees look at the people
sitting on either side of you imagine
one was was a refugee forced to seek
haven in your country because her family
had been driven from their own in Jordan
we have to be concerned with the
conflict because we are living with its
consequences we don't have the luxury of
shifting our focus away we know as well
that the crisis in Palestine does not
exist in a vacuum what happens in
Palestine is related to what happens in
Iraq in Lebanon and Syria the longer the
conflict in Palestine
persists the weaker the moderate
majority becomes the more extremists
gain leverage they can exploit and the
greater the risk of instability
throughout our region so we appreciated
President Obama's outreach in his Cairo
speech we appreciated his
acknowledgement that the conflict
remains a major source of tension
between us and his pledge to pursue a
two-state solution with patience and
dedication we appreciated the
appointment of Senator George Mitchell
as a special envoy we are impatient when
it comes to Palestine time has not been
a friend to the contrary sometimes
Palestine seems like the land that time
forgot you know when I started college
back in 1988 Europe was divided the
United States had an existential phone
called the USSR much of Latin America
was ruled by hunters South Africa by
apartheid civil conflicts had been
raging for decades from Guatemala to
Northern Ireland Nelson Mandela lived in
a cell and Palestine was occupied these
were the problems we used to describe as
intractable even insoluble yet hatreds
have given way to handshakes prisoners
have become presidents but not in
Palestine in Palestine walls are going
up not coming down 400 kilometers to be
precise the decades have brought what
feels like an endless parade of starts
and stalemates missed opportunities
shattered hopes and diminishing returns
and I'm not here to talk about blame
that doesn't get us anywhere
it's like tracing your finger on a
mobius strip going round in an infinite
loop but coming from Jordan I feel I
must speak for those voices that
Americans rarely hear to describe the
sense of identity theft the Palestinians
have endured for over 60 years because
their pain is more is about more than
just the loss of their land their olive
trees their livelihoods their grief is
more it's about more than just being
kicked out of their homes in which their
families have lived for generations as
one scholar put it land is the geography
of the Palestinian soul they're very
understanding of who they are is deeply
rooted in the
of their environment so each new claim
on their ever shrinking space feels like
a blow to their very existence having no
place to call their own
is like having no identity at all think
about it when you enroll here at Yale
one of the first things you receive is
an ID it allows you access to
residential colleges dining halls the
library stacks it opens doors it gets
you in it shows that you belong and when
you leave Yale you get a piece of paper
to carry with you a diploma that gives
you status before you ever have to say a
word in the West Bank and Gaza young
people like you are given an ID as well
but this ID is not about access it's
only about limitation it limits the
boundaries of where they can go what
they can do who they can be it's a
constant reminder that in other's eyes
they are less valuable less important
simply less UN sources report that
almost 40 percent of the West Bank is
now covered by his resettlement related
Israeli infrastructure barriers buffer
zones military bases barbed wire and
barricades parents can't get to work
students can't get to class sick people
can't get to hospitals all traffic is
stopped from people on foot to cars and
trucks to ambulances the way it can be
hours often only to find that passages
refused relatives detained on their way
to a family wedding children searched
their notes ripped from their
schoolbooks grandparents forced to stand
for hours holding packages and heavy
bags the unpredictability anxiety and
humiliation are as wearing as a delay
and so much more than freedom of
movement is lost when each day is
defined by these checkpoints with armed
soldiers demanding hawea ID Howey ID
show me proof that you exist the
degradation is compounded by the sense
that no one cares that the outside world
world is oblivious to the hardships
Palestinians endure especially in Gaza
were for two years families have faced
the collective punishment of Locke Aid
and for three months at the start of
this year
they were subjected to devastating
attack with no place to run and nowhere
to hide
not even UN hospitals or schools today a
million people almost 40 70 percent of
Gaza's population are refugees homes lie
in rubble hospitals lack power sewage
pipes threatened to burst the economy
has totally utterly collapsed
unemployment is approaching 50 percent
one resident calls it a jail where no
prisoner knows the length of his
sentence and not one penny of the
billions of dollars pledged for
reconstruction has gotten through more
than half the population of Gaza is
under the age of 18 children did not
create this conflict but they are its
greatest victims just listen to the
words of the four small children who
were found by the Red Cross in January
in the shell battered neighborhood is a
tune clinging to their mothers corpses
they couldn't speak they were too weak
to stand they hadn't eaten for days
while the fire fight raged outside the
door and their families died inside they
survived and they're alive but that's
not the same as surviving these children
had nothing but their mother's love and
now they have lost that too and the
worst threat of all is the cynicism so
many people feel the sense that Middle
East peace is hopeless that we'll never
find a solution because if we throw up
our hands and say this problem is too
hard we're not just writing off a
process or writing off a road map we're
writing off people's lives but let me be
clear it isn't just the Palestinians
lives that are at stake here Israelis to
need a future of peace and security they
too need to be free of wailing sirens
announcing an attack and they too need
to grow up to grow to grow up without
the shadow of walls and watchtowers for
as a columnist from and leading Israeli
daily wrote the spring one of the
casualties of occupation may be a
healthy state of Israel itself
so what must be done on the political
front we need courage accountability and
action and we see signs of hope as
President Obama and his team invest
their time and capital in breathing life
into negotiations for two viable secure
sovereign states we see signs of hope as
all 22 members of the Arab League have
offered Israel full recognition in
exchange for withdrawal to its pre-1967
border we see signs of hope as brave
people on both sides say they are ready
to give peace a chance
64% of Palestinians and 40% of Israelis
who support the Arab League plan now all
sides must take responsibility for
building on this momentum and let me say
clearly the responsibility includes the
Arab world we decry the actions of
Israeli extremists but must work harder
to rein in our own we look to the West
to do more in support of palestinian
needs but must do our part and must
press the palestinians towards unity
among themselves at the same time as my
husband His Majesty King Abdullah has
said it is time for Israel to choose to
integrate into the region accepted and
accepting with normal relations with its
neighbors or to remain fortress Israel
isolated and holding itself in the
entire region a hostage to continuing
confrontation and form America - we need
sustained commitment creative engagement
and leadership to keep the parties on
the path to peaceful coexistence but we
need even more because true peace
depends not just on new lines on a map
it is not just the walls on the land
that must go we have to take down the
walls in our hearts there has been so
much pain so much loss so much fear so
much hatred and mistrust true peace
depends on reconnecting the bonds of our
common humanity I was moved by something
JK Rowling said in her commencement at
Harvard last year she said that humans
have the unique ability to think
themselves into other people's places to
learn and understand new things
they haven't actually experienced and
yet many choose to remain comfortably
within the bounds of their own
experience never troubling to wonder how
would you feel to have been born other
than they are they can refuse to hear
screams or to peer inside cages they can
close their minds and hearts to any
suffering that doesn't touch them
personally they can refuse to no Rowling
went on to say I might be tempted to
envy people who can live that way except
that I do not think that they have any
fewer nightmares than I do
I think the willfully unimaginative see
more monsters she said they are more
afraid she is right so often we dread
what we do not know we live in fear of
the things we cannot see but we'll never
move forward by closing ourselves off
the only way to grow is to reach out to
truly make peace in the Middle East or
anywhere in the world we all have to
learn to think ourselves into other
people's places to put ourselves in
other people's shoes to make room for
others beep people's hopes and fears for
the more we appreciate one another's
perspective the more dimension and depth
we add to our own and in many respects
that's what a liberal education is all
about it's about asking questions
without prejudicing the answers during
lessons from other people's experiences
testing and refining our own values and
beliefs developing the habits of an open
mind when we shine the light of inquiry
broad-mindedness and compassion that is
how we find our way to our own best
selves the more open we become the more
we find we can contain it's the lux that
leads the way to the very task and when
it comes to the Middle East no matter
how great the fears no matter how deep
them is trust if we shine that light we
are sure to reveal what has always and
will always be true there is no
difference between the love the
Palestinians and Israelis feel for their
children no difference between their
laughter or their tears we share one
humanity as one of my heroes
tuturro likes to say we all of us have
been made for goodness we have been made
for laughter we have been made for
caring for sharing for compassion for we
do indeed inhabit a moral universe and
yes
goodness is powerful Yale as global
citizens we have a responsibility to one
another in our interconnected world
there are no zero-sum games we win or
lose together we all have a stake in
peace and justice for all of us
are diminished by their absence let us
work together in the Middle East and
around the world to make peace come true
for good thank you all very much
I want to thank the audience for
submitting so many possible questions
here I've trying to sift through but I
will take the privilege of the chair and
start with one or two of my own inspired
by your remarks I I think III think the
reaction of the audience suggests that
we were everyone here finds your appeal
to open-mindedness and to hope for a
solution in the Middle East particularly
with respect to Israel and Palestine to
be something inspiring and motivating
for us all I I think one question to ask
is what role can the United States play
you spoke of President Obama's charting
in a direction are there ways that
President Obama and the United States
can be can give an assist to this
process and in particular what kinds of
actions might be called for on our part
absolutely
I really do believe that the two sides
cannot do it on their own and the United
States plays an instrumental role in
getting the two sides around the
negotiating table the United States has
a role to play in terms of remaining
offering leadership remaining engaged to
being committed to the process we need
the United States to be a to be like to
show the leadership and in the process
to lead the way to enforce to be a
referee to give guardianship there are
so many sticking issues out there and
you know settlement is what the
settlement is one of the issues that
that have been obstacle most recently
and we need to want to be a fair broker
between the two sides and it comes with
the realization that peace is not just
of strategic interest to the
Palestinians and Israelis themselves but
for the entire world and for the United
States as well
there's pieces and one thing that's
going to undermine the extremists in the
region and undermine the radical
ideology that has emerged in recent
years so we all have a vested interest
in making sure that this conflict is
resolved once and for all and
unfortunately you know we've had so much
process we've had so many you know we
don't need political leaders and
politicians dealing with papers we need
politicians dealing with people we don't
need process we need projects on the
ground because the the you know
incremental steps that have been taken
have really frustrated people and
they've made people lose hope in the
process and they just feed the agendas
of those who are who are opposed to
peace so we need a concise and and
concrete and tangible steps on the
ground that can really improve the lives
of people in Palestine in Israel
clearly that's the central issue for for
the Obama administration to deal with in
the Middle East are there others are
there other things that the Arab world
would look to this country to do over
the over the years ahead into in terms
of strengthening you know if there's one
thing that that undermines us
credibility in our region it is that
issue because it is you know I think the
world looks judges the United States
when Israel breaks international law or
when they don't honor their commitments
for example with the building of the
separation wall with the expansion of
the settlements with a changes on the
ground that have changed a multi-faith
character of Jerusalem people feel that
Israel will not have been able to do
that if the United States did not
condone this so the one thing that could
really build up the credibility and show
goodwill is if we reach a fair and just
solution to this issue of course
outreach to the Arab world is very
important and President Obama's approach
and his diplomacy with our region his
vision for a relationship that's based
on mutual trust and mutual interests has
really been welcomed in the arab world
of course you know you
of the issues in Iraq and and you know
there is the obvious solution Iran and
all of those areas but I think it's a
matter of engaging the Arab world
listening to and having a real measured
and studied approach when you deal with
with our region um let me take one
question for the audience that you've
been very vocal proponent of the UN
Millennium Goals obviously we all have
concerns and we just as a report last
week about how the slowdown in the in
the worldwide economy has affected
prospects for realizing the school's you
know that hunger and and some areas is
actually worsening not getting better
what what's your prognosis how do you
see any prospect of reaching those goals
by 2050 so in the year 2000 world
leaders came together and they came up
with eight promises that they made for
this world you know ending hunger
getting children to school reducing a
child mortality dealing with vermin so
it's just eight promises and we're
supposed to reach them by the year 2015
and you know that was those promises
were a mandate to change the story of
human history and you know it's been
said that promises are unique a human
way of ordering the future so back then
world leaders had the compassion the
commitment to make those promises
now we're two-thirds of the way there
and as you mentioned I think we're far
from reaching many of those goals the
one that I've been focusing on the most
is education and today we have about
seventy five million children out of
school to get them into school will
require eleven billion dollars a year
which might might sound like a lot but
it is less than what the wars in
Afghanistan and Iraq cost in one month
so when you think about it's actually
the bargain of the century it's the best
investment we can make what's required
is for us to create the critical mass of
supporters for these for these goals so
that the so that their leaders feel the
pressure
to fulfill their commitments and fulfil
the pledges that they made for those
children developing world I think you
know we all owe it to to the mothers and
fathers who want to give their children
education just like you know we all care
your parents cared about sending you
here because they understand how
critical it is for the way that your gut
life is going to look for you to get a
quality education so what we really
requires more awareness and rallying of
the public behind some of these goals no
education of course has been a major
emphasis of your own in in Jordan and we
look at it of course from a bit of a
parochial perspective we would like to
see more Middle Eastern students come to
this country and I think as we know we
were talking just before this session
about the dropping off of applicants to
the United States from the Middle East
right after 9/11 in the first few years
we recently the numbers have started to
turn back up overall international
applications have actually up seven
percent last year but they're still
reluctant in the Middle East to come to
the United States and what can places
like Yale do to help convince you know
your constituencies and your and and
others in the Middle East that this is a
welcoming and a friendly place in that
we actually want Middle Eastern students
what strategies you would recommend for
us well let me let me start by saying
that the United States status in the
world this was not born out of its size
or military might or politics around the
world it was it comes from the
principles and values upon which this
country was found because the United
States is more than a country it is a
concept it is a concept of openness
diversity tolerance acceptance or
autocracy innovation philanthropy all of
these are the values that make the
United States what is it what it is in
the world good advertisement for the
United States
so so to keep that status I think the
United States will be well advised to
preserve those values and not having a
being able to open your doors to the
best and brightest from all over the
world it's extremely instrumental to be
able to maintain these values and you
know I see all over the world other
countries who are you know building
great universities trying to attract
students out hate to see the United
States slide in that regard so it's so
important for you to maintain that
diversity to maintain that openness to
really attract people from old well it's
only it would be a loss to the states if
you didn't and one way to do that is to
reassure those young people that they
will be treated fairly if they come to
this country that they they don't want
to be discriminated against they want to
be singled out and unfortunately some
starett of stereotypes have been quite
pervasive and that has scared a lot of
people from my part of the world from
coming to the United States and so
they've chosen to go to Europe or Canada
or any other country so and I hope that
this trend is reversed and a little bit
of openness and acceptance I think will
go a long way I think that's you know I
certainly agree actually does us there's
a question from one of the students in
the audience that relates to this
question of stereotyping at which you
might want to tackle which is and I read
this one exactly there's discussion
among Arabs here Arab students here in
the United States about who has more of
a responsibility to break down
stereotypes Arabs or non Arabs because
both have stereotypes of each other and
there's not always agreement so what do
you think of this line of argument does
one group have more responsibility than
the other or absolutely I've no doubt in
my mind that both groups have an equal
amount of effort to do this is about a
dialogue involves two people and has to
go both ways
we are just as guilty of stereotypes
towards the west as the Western
substrate types towards us and you know
there there has been
a gulf that has emerged in recent years
particularly after 9/11 and it's
incumbent about all of us moderates to
to try to break that you know the one
thing I find is that extremists and
those are the radical ideology they are
willing to act on their beliefs but the
moderates are are not as willing you
know they they may show apathy we can
sometimes be lazy but what's the point
of having beliefs if we don't act on
them you know if we are for openness and
and diversity and equal rights and
freedoms what's the point of having that
that those beliefs without without
really doing something about it and
that's where the that's where the
radicals and extremists have won upon us
because for example you know we find
that in countries around the world
education is a battleground with youth
are being on the front lines and
extremists try to get in there and fill
their minds with content you know with
extreme ideologies with with hatred
towards the rest of the world with
preaching violence but what are we doing
we're not even going there so you know
we need to we need to go into the areas
that we have left vacant and that is
primarily our youths Minds and try to
get them in the right direction and you
all have a very important role to do
well you get them to believe in the
values you articulated about what
America stands for and we will try to
get President Obama to get a solution
have a deal
I know that another passion of yours is
our women's issues and the rights and
women and indeed the opportunities for
women and actually there are a number of
questions from the audience I'll try to
just pick one about that issue and this
I think this is an interesting one could
you give us some specific ways in that
by which women's empowerment could be
achieved in an Islamic cultural context
are there are there special avenues or
the particular things that could be done
to one thing one thing I find I found
over the years a bit frustrating is that
when people look at women in Muslim
countries they tend to you know look at
our region as a one monolithic whole
when the reality is that different women
in different countries are in different
circumstances and have achieved
different levels of progress so there's
no single mold for an Arab woman just
like there is no single mold for an
American woman you know the status of
women and the Arab world and Muslim
world depends on her upbringing her
family her education etc so that's one
thing that we have to clear and no
stereotype to another series to a
breakdown and that in many countries in
in the Arab world women are making
incredible progress some countries they
face many challenges we some we
definitely have to work on some of the
legal aspects and illegal rights for
women we have to work on the education
to break down some of the stereotypes
that are in our curricula and most
importantly we have to get more women in
the workplace because we find that
although we've attained high levels of
education for women not many women are
going into into the workplace so there
are many challenges that we have to
overcome but the one thing that I always
sort of encounter it's it's the mind
sets you know it's it's a joke
perceptions its societal habits that
just need to be changed and refined
those are the things that those are the
obstacles that hold women back and more
and more we really have to focus on on
changing those one student asks how has
Jordan been affected by the global
financial crisis is this is this man
caused you difficulties sort of with
your own agenda
in absolutely I don't think any country
has not been affected by the crisis now
we have some countries in our region
that are doing quite well especially
some of the Gulf countries the oil-rich
countries
fortunately Jordan is not one of those
but we found that you know some of the
investment foreign direct investment
into Jordan has been reduced you know a
lot of the Jordanians that used to work
abroad some of them have lost their jobs
so remittances the remittances have gone
down a little you know we're affected by
the tourism maybe being weakened so we
you know we have been affected to some
extent but you know we're still moving
forward we're still working on our
reforms economic reforms and and and
political reforms so you know it slowed
us down a little bit but we're hopefully
I'm moving forward so the political
issue of the moment here in the United
States is health care reform yes um
watch them is that what yeah what so one
stit one student here who is I guess
studying for both an MD and an MBA is
asking what do you what do you think of
the what we what are two quests two-part
question what are the health care
challenges today in your country and
this one I doubt you'll answer the
second one what what what do you think
should be done in the United States we
check it was guys more first yeah I
think you know we have the challenge of
providing health insurance for our
population and trying to cover as many
people as possible
so obviously it's focusing on the the
regulations the the policies that the
the quality control we have a lot of
people we actually have some of the best
doctors in the region and a lot of
people come to Jordan for treatments so
with that you want to make sure that
this doesn't become a commercialized
sector and that you maintain the quality
integrity of the professions so but yes
we do face challenges because of our I
cannot financial challenges Jordan is
not a rich country and so we're not able
to
we give everybody the quality of health
care that we'd like as to what should be
done in this country that is a very
complicated debate and the one thing
that I will say is that President Obama
I don't know if his plan is the right
one or not but he is going about it in a
very studied kind of way I know that
he's reached out to many people in the
sector try to get as much input as
possible try to process this information
as well as he can there is no perfect
plan for the United States eventually
they're gonna have to make a choice and
make that that make sure that that
choice works but staying in a state of
limbo I think is not really benefiting
anyone the United States um he talked
about women I was you talk about the
importance of increasing labor force
participation are there specific
measures you're taking Jordan to try to
make that happen or anything creative
being done in the region to actually
help women enter the labor force I mean
presumably your own example of being a
woman in a leadership position and being
so visible and so out front on so many
social issues probably is an inspiration
are there concrete policies that have
helped that helped in the in the in the
Arab world are the major challenges that
we face is creating enough jobs so the
challenges for women and for our youth
now for us to purchase to prevent a rise
in unemployment we have to create 3.5
million jobs a year and that's a lot and
we're having a problem of supply and
demand on the other side the quality of
the education generally provided is not
what it should be a lot of our
educational systems are a little bit
outdated they focus on rote learning and
memorization and as opposed to critical
thinking problem-solving creative
creativity so we need to update the way
we teach and make sure that our young
people are better prepared to enter the
workplace whether they're girls or boys
so so on the one end we're trying to
work on fixing the educational system
and then also to try to smooth out the
transition from school to work
you know by offering vocational training
by getting some of the private sector
people involved in the process so they
provide internship
training they let us know what their
demands are from the young people so
that we graduate the kind of people that
they want to hire but it's a complicated
thing when it comes to them and again
it's it's through example we have so
many women now if you think twenty years
ago in the Arab world there were only a
handful of women in government now
almost every country has female
ministers we have women CEOs we have
women in the judiciary system so there
they're there we're making tremendous
progress but we're nowhere near where we
should be but the trend is it's positive
and moving forward and I think that's
that's what matters and perceptions are
changing very quickly but you know
editing attitudes takes a while you know
so there are actually a whole host of
questions from the audience about you
about you as a person
so most appropriate following that
answer would be would be perhaps this
one how do you balance you know we talk
about work and life balance family and
family and work and workplace balance
how do you balance your responsibilities
as a mother and a family member on the
one hand and and Queen you know I've
been asked this question so many times
you know
and every time I say I'm gonna get the
answer but I never do because it really
isn't one you know there isn't a set
formula for getting it right all the
time and it's just a matter of trying
your best every time prioritizing you
know there are times when my children
take precedence there are times when a
particular project take it there isn't
one way of doing it but it's I've
learned to be kinder to myself over the
years and realize that I can't do
everything well all the time that
something's got to give and that's okay
you know it's alright if you don't get
it 100% you know it's as long as you do
your best you know and that's what I try
to do I'm sure you so I think adopting a
relaxed approach about about it is it's
probably the best way to go well your
majesty you've been an inspiration to
all of us that really I think everyone
appreciates the forthrightness of your
responses these questions your your
open-mindedness your energy and your
compassion for Humanity it's fabulous to
have you here I'm going to close by
asking you to deliver on this most
admiring of all the questions we
received and Alex you may claim this if
you if you come to my office sometime
tomorrow this this work this question is
your Majesty would you please autograph
this
you